[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy monday for joe
biden the past few months have amounted
to the greatest political disaster of
his life in his case that's not a small
place to be this is a man with three
failed presidential campaigns on his
resume but this year has been different
now we don't mean to overstate it but
you can pick your humiliating ashes in
south cloth world historic defeat
stalingrad corregidor gallipoli and
that's pretty much where joe biden is
right now politically
polls show him losing astounding levels
of support from virtually every group of
americans who voted for him just a year
ago that would include hispanics
moderate democrats african americans and
by big double digits independence
at this point the white house is down to
just two core constituencies anxious
upper income women with multiple college
degrees and barren personal lives and
members of the national news media and
even that may be overstating biden's
support given that there's such dramatic
overlap between those two groups
essentially they're the same people
and now because it can always get worse
biden appears to be losing even the
media
this is an ominous development in fact
it's not an exaggeration to say that if
this trend continues it is the end of
the biden presidency the media are the
only reason joe biden is president in
the first place but didn't campaign for
the job he didn't hold rallies or give
speeches or tell the public what he
might do if elected
no for nearly a year joe biden stayed
home hiding in terror from infectious
voters instead he let news organizations
make his case for him which they
assiduously did the media hid biden's
faults they attacked and censored his
critics in general they gave him no hint
at all that you might be electing a
senile mannequin with a lifelong history
of sleazy behavior
voters had no clue they didn't know who
joe biden actually was and yet suddenly
news organizations have decided to tell
them
it's pretty amazing to watch it here's
some clips from just the last few days
president joe biden has had a very tough
week with setbacks for his agenda covid
complications and the supreme court
blocking his vaccine mandate one year in
mr biden has the second lowest approval
rating ever measured in the white house
and has never been less popular
nationally 2022 is not exactly off to a
good start for the biden administration
the country is frustrated his party is
frustrated we're two weeks into a
midterm election year a few days away
from his one year anniversary of
inauguration and it is black it is very
dark for him right now now he's in the
midst of what one famous children's book
writer called a terrible horrible no
good very bad
time
oh a very tough week of setbacks the
country is frustrated
that's cnn's assessment if it sounds
mild to you you should consider the
source cnn criticizing a sitting
democratic president that's like the
college of cardinals attacking the pope
it is a violation of ecclesiastical
authority you never see it and when it
happens it means something
msnbc went even further than that one of
its contributors decided to come out and
tell the channel's viewers something
they had never heard before joe biden is
old really really old possibly too old
to govern a nation of 335 million people
watch this your audience is not going to
be happy with what i have to say is i
don't think he's come across as an
inspirational figure i i don't think by
the way you i could give a litany of
things he's accomplished and obviously
and jonathan laid out things that have
not gone well for him but there's
something else different how many people
do you talk to
when they say
he seems old
and i don't mean that as an aegis thing
he doesn't and it really started with
afghanistan where he just didn't seem to
have his hand firmly on the wheel and i
think a lot of this has to do with the
messenger versus the messages itself he
doesn't feel in charge
now wait a second now
you're telling us that joe biden doesn't
quote seem to have his hand firmly on
the wheel
really you sure we're talking about the
same president here
wasn't this the guy who not so long ago
was challenging strangers to push up
contests at town halls this is the guy
who single-handedly rescued nelson
mandela from the hell of robben island
this is the man who faced down corn pop
with a chain at a public swimming pool
now you're saying that man that chiseled
monument to decisive masculinity maybe
losing his grip
yep that's exactly what they're saying
and they seem almost bashfully
apologetic as they say it they had no
idea joe biden was a lumbering
desiccated husk no idea at all
they never saw biden colony when a dog
paced
pony soldier
they didn't notice him sniffing
anybody's hair or staring blankly into
the middle distance like a lobotomy
patient they never saw it they're as
shocked as you are
watch cnn's resident nobel prize winner
come to the awful conclusion that maybe
joe biden isn't doing an amazing job as
president
president biden left washington tonight
to spend the weekend at home in delaware
he probably couldn't wait to get out of
town after one of the worst weeks of his
year old presidency a series of setbacks
on voting rights the supreme court
blocking his vaccine mandate for large
businesses and soaring inflation driving
up prices for consumers and today we saw
the news at retail sales last month were
awful plus omicron is still causing
havoc with staffing shortages and empty
shelves and some set of democrats are
upset with the white house over testing
shortages
i i mean i could go on
but i mean is that any it was it's a bad
week for the president is there any way
to cut it another way to say it
so by joe biden's never at the white
house and he's right about that but it's
possible cnn missed the larger point
biden isn't fleeing washington because
he's upset about political defeats biden
is being dragged into isolation by
advisers who are terrified he will get
corona like everyone else right now they
want him out of the city as quickly as
possible they know exactly how well
masks and vaccines work they're not
betting on dr fauci's guidance but
whatever details details the point is
cnn is running away from joe biden
even don lemon can see where this is
going he may be stupid but his animal
instincts are fully intact don lemon can
recognize a sinking ship when he sees
one and he's decided to disembark as
swiftly as he can make for the lifeboats
cnn anchors first
maybe if people like don lemon
repeatedly make disappointed noises
about joe biden no one will remember how
they sounded a year ago and hold them
responsible for this disaster but we
will we remember we saved the tape
here's don lemon weeping with joy over
joe biden's election like jesus had just
returned to make gym memberships free
and forgive everybody's student loans
watch
how you feeling
it's
i almost can't talk right now because of
the emotion
everyone is welcome under this tent we
don't care who you are
we don't care if you voted for us or not
you're all part of this american
experiment
it was i was so overwhelmed to hear that
i don't care what people think if they
think i'm biased or not
i don't care and so i'm very emotional
so when you ask me how i'm feeling right
now
i'm sorry that's all i can tell you this
is how i feel right now i am so happy to
have this platform to be able to do this
i may not have it after this but i
really don't care i am so
happy
we don't care if you voted for us not
joe biden for us
meaning joe biden's friends and
co-conspirators over at cena i really
don't care i'm so happy
that's the tape there you have it
if this were a trial that would be the
pivotal evidence the glove fits ladies
and gentlemen of the jury you cannot
acquit
the media foisted this biden calamity on
the united states they got him elected
then they lied and distracted the
population as he and the marionette
operators who controlled him wrecked a
lot of this country
that happened and it's too late now to
deny responsibility these people are
fully implicated in what they did lots
of them are it's not just don lamont
watch this member of congress from
silicon valley one of the smarter
members we've got to say decide that
actually maybe big tech shouldn't have
censored legitimate stories truthful
stories about hunter biden's laptop
after all maybe that was a mistake watch
i am not for uh having either the
government or
uh you know tech companies ultimately
the arbiter of truth uh i'm for making
sure censorship that we don't have
speech that incites violence but i'm
very wary of censorship in fact you know
in the book i write about uh how uh i i
thought it was a mistake for twitter to
take down some of the stuff about hunter
biden or uh or facebook to do that and i
think that story was total hogwash i
think joe biden was unfairly attacked
because of his son but that doesn't mean
that it didn't belong in the public
sphere
oh you're not for censorship oh you're
not for censorship thanks for that
congressman great but where were you and
it mattered say last october right
before the election when people were
trying to figure out who to vote for oh
you were staying dead silent like the
rest of them you were letting it happen
you were allowing democracy to corrode
and die because at the time you thought
it was worth it
donald trump was just too scary trump
was an emergency so we had to suspend
the constitution to make this into an
unfree country we had no choice
but now that he's in office some of
these people are apparently having
second thoughts now
but why now
what exactly is going on here and why is
everyone suddenly saying the same thing
at once we could answer the second part
of that question with absolute certainty
everyone in the democratic party sounds
exactly alike because the message
discipline is what they do it's who they
are no one in the party thinks
independently that's not allowed
everybody in the group must say the very
same thing in concert with everybody
else in the group all the time period
it's like a north korean singing troop
deviationists are punished
think for yourself even for a second and
you are denounced as a conspiracy
theorist who thinks horse dewormer is
medicine
you see it every day we can give you a
million examples of this our producer
tom fox the genius who finds our tape
every night for the show often says he's
got the most repetitive job in
television because everybody on every
channel sounds exactly the same all the
time
here's one recent chorus of dummies
lies that would bring thousands of angry
people to the capitol for one of
america's darkest days became one of the
darkest days in american political
history very next day was one of the
darkest days in this nation's history to
one of the most dramatic and dark days
in american history one of the darkest
days in u.s history this was one of the
darkest days in american history and we
expect the president to say just that
now all these very same people are
simultaneously trashing the president
they got elected and have defended
through everything for a year why
now we're not alleging an intentional
conspiracy here we don't take horse
dewormer we're not saying there was a
secret conference call between jeff
zucker joy reid and the staff of the
atlantic magazine who'd even want to
endure something like that more likely
it's a conspiracy of instinct for all
the talk you hear of diversity there is
precisely zero diversity in our national
media people may have different skin
tones or different sexual interests not
relevant
they're all from such similar
backgrounds with such similar beliefs
and values and life experiences that
their gut reactions to everything have
aligned into perfect synchronicity like
menstruating teenagers at summer camp
they speak as one because on the deepest
level they're indistinguishable from
each other
but still you wonder there's got to be
some kind of political point to this
there's got to be no one at cnn is ever
going to undermine the long-term
prospects of the democratic party at
least not intentionally
if they snatch the walker from joe
biden's hands and that's exactly what
they're doing who do they think is going
to take over when he falls
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else